Nancy Pelosi's house was broken into
Paul Pelosi her husband it's like two in
the morning or whatever he's in his
underwear some guy apparently breaks in
they get into a fight now a whole lot of
information comes out information is
changing everybody's trying to figure
out what's really going on the first
story was that like cops showed up and
an unknown man let him in and then they
see you know Paul Pelosi's fighting over
a hammer with this guy who then beats
him then they arrest the guy people are
so so here's what it breaks down to on
the left they say this guy posted Q Anon
conspiracy theories and he was a
radicalized trump supporter on the right
they're saying his house and this is
true has a pride flag a BLM flag and
like a unite against hate sign in the
window and the neighbors say they were
like hippie nudists hemp weaving
leftists
so there's that story the right that I'm
seeing the memes is that the guy who
attacked Paul was a gay prostitute the
glass on the door was broken from the
inside so the glass went outside and
that Paul Pelosi called the police and
said he was a friend
I think both of those stories go a
little too far I think it's fair to say
we don't know exactly what happened and
it's probably what what they're saying
about this guy being a cute cultist I
don't believe he was a registered Green
Party Guy but for before we get into it
I just want to say a couple things the
reason why I think Paul Pelosi said he
was a friend if you listen to the police
report uh the 911 dispatch call
you wake up in the morning some guy
breaks in your house he's not
immediately attacking you he says
where's Nancy what do you do do you say
start screaming and swinging at him love
your 82. so the story apparently is that
he went to his bathroom where his phone
was and then called the police my
assumption is that he told the guy oh
yeah yeah don't worry just wait right
here call the cops I I you know hey
there's a guy in my house and the cop
probably said do you know who he is and
he goes no and they said okay and then
Paul goes he's a friend he's waiting for
my wife
because you've got a crazy guy saying
you know what I'm saying crazy guy
sitting in front of you I don't think
Paul's head to the police off to the
place on the phone hi I just want to let
you know there's a guy I don't know in
my house and he's a friend I'm waiting
for my wife I think the police asked him
he said he probably said hey there's a
man in my house he's a friend he's
waiting for my wife the cops probably
said do you know this man he said no so
that this guy didn't hear what he was
saying I think that's entirely plausible
why is the glass on the outside because
the guy breaks it in and then pulls the
glass out to reach it and get the door
handle I don't know now I think the
story's not doesn't completely make
sense this guy was a leftist so the
story about him being a q Anon cultist
doesn't seem to make sense but I don't
know what do you guys think well did you
the official police reports say that
Paul called him a friend on the phone
with the cop yes uh I don't think ever
if there's a break-in that you would
tell the police your friend is over if a
crazy person broke in your house and
started telling you Ian that you needed
to help him right now to stop the Gnomes
who stole your spoons and you said would
you would you be like let me call the
police and they'll get us no no I'd turn
the fan on in the bathroom but there's a
psychopath in my living room like maybe
I wouldn't even I wouldn't lie to lock
the door to the bathroom close it there
there's there's also a couple things
that make you kind of wonder what's
going on here the Pelosi's are some of
the richest people in the world and some
of the most powerful and influential
people in the world that have had their
home targeted before by political
activists and they had no surgery they
had no security they had no one they had
no play their decision that they they
they intentionally like refused security
yeah that's what they're saying yes
that's that's absolutely just
mind-boggling and and especially yeah if
you're doing something Shady like like
they do in House of Cards which uh by
the way uh Bill Clinton said is uh 99
accurate
um maybe then I would understand that
but there's also another another thing
that happened here specifically with the
political reporting that police told
them that there was an unknown person
that let them in political is now
reporting that this is a baseless claim
when they originally reported on it now
I want to say I want to say this guys
all of this the whole story something
doesn't add up that's clear as day right
yeah it is a good point if he was able
to go into his bathroom and close the
door but where his phone was charging we
don't know why I mean and where's the
body cam footage I mean but it's it's so
it's early it's early right here's what
I want to say though I want to say I
want to say this
I think the gay prostitute narrative is
the trick is a trick because once
everyone starts posting memes about this
crazy story about a leftist gay
prostitute it makes any regular person
be like what
get Audi it's ridiculous
a break-in sounds plausible they're
trying to turn the story about a
break-in into a q Anon far-right cultist
so I don't know I don't know for sure
wasn't the story that the guy that broke
in was screaming about Nancy like what I
want Nancy that to me sounds like I
found the guy's passport and the
wreckage on 911. it fell out of the
Flaming ball of airplane and landed on
the ground this proves that he was in
the plane you're like what kind of
psycho story is that passwords don't
fall out of burning explosive Rubble
like uh and also they don't prove
anything if they did and and just just
having someone tell me that a guy
screamed something political is like
that just sounds like a red hair well
Cass sunstein Obama's disinformations
are openly talked about how they need to
spread fake conspiracy theories in order
to make the legitimate conspiracy
theories look bad he also talked about
the importance of infiltrating 911
family members who were victims of the
attacks that happened in New York City
in order to of course send in more
propaganda more disinformation in order
to confuse every everyone and make
everyone look bad who were legitimately
asking questions this is what I'm saying
right it the story can be something
much simpler than people are making it
out to be
it could be that Paul Pelosi was doing
something embarrassing with a local guy
who's a leftist maybe they were friends
something bad happened and they're
trying to cover it up there's two ways
you do it the guy was a cute cultist and
then you get the right to push the most
absurd story possible that no one would
ever believe and here we go I'm seeing
all the memes that are like Paul
Pelosi's gay lover is trending and I'm
like that's how they get you he was
driving the drunk a couple years a year
ago or something and who was the guy who
was with him when he was driving his car
drone oh I don't know was there a guy
with him so so here's my point for all
we know this guy could have been
delivering Drugs That's substantially
more more reasonable and plausible if
you go to a regular person and say do
you think high profile members of the
government do drugs
yes do you think powerful CEOs and
Executives do drugs of course that it's
a move it's like a movie trout they're
doing coke all the time do you think
it's possible that a drug deal could go
bad a small one like a guy's dropping
off at two in the morning some blow or
something that's that's happened okay so
do you think it's possible this could be
something like that yeah maybe but the
guy was reportedly accused cultist I'm
like what do you think is more plausible
that one of the most secure places in
the country the third in line for the
presidency had no security and a fringe
conspiracy theorist was able to break in
and the government didn't know about it
or do was trying to buy some below and
it went bad right and there to me it's
clear the the social condition that's
going on everything the left does right
now is blamed on you know Maga terrorism
white supremacist terrorism they're
trying to I mean if you any uh you know
four-star general from the military or
you know any corporate CEO you know
whatever it is they're all going to tell
you in a congressional hearing you know
the number one threat to America these
days is maggot terrorism white
supremacist terrorism and again like I
think if there's going to be an
explanation for this you know incident
whatever it is you know that's their
go-to card and I just think they're
they're playing that card every single
time because they're conditioning
everyone to to anticipate that
um you know that eventuality I do
believe the likely scenarios that what
kind of what you were saying Tim that it
that it was like some sort of late night
rendezvous that that got heated or
something like that and they probably
knew each other and and it could be gay
prostitution I just think that is a more
shocking and difficult to believe story
and it's really the worst case scenario
that Paul is doing some blow of some
dude it got out of hand and then he
grabbed a hammer I guess like get out
it's time for you to leave and the guy's
like I'm not leaving Paul we're doing
another line and they were like oh now
there was something about a wellness
check like the cops weren't even called
there originally due to the disturbance
it was a wellness check on Paul as part
of his probation yeah I mean that was in
the original reporting was that they
were they were called there on a
wellness check was that from was that
from when he got caught during driving
is it the yes at 2 A.M at 2 A.M cool so
hold on
no double check me on this because that
was that was the original the original
story I heard was that the cops were
there doing a wellness check and then
that escalated because the hammer didn't
come out like the the in the original
political article they said that Paul
was not attacked with the hammer until
the police arrived it wasn't it wasn't
like they broke up a hammer attack it's
like the police showed up and then the
struggle over the hammer ensued that was
what I heard so like this I got
dispatcher Heather Grimes had said
something was wrong with the situation
an ordered officials to conduct an
expedited wellness check on the home
look at this the glass is broken it so
the glass on both the outside and the
inside people need to understand it I'm
seeing a lot of people say the glass on
the outside you can see the glasses
clearly inside and outside yeah you
could have pulled it out as he was
breaking right right right right so I I
know what Dudu once kicked a glass
window your foot his foot went through
it because it was safety glass and when
he pulled it out he raked it out serious
with his arms and then he shredded his
arms he's not yank your arms out if you
go through windows stay there and stay
calm yep but anyway glass comes out the
other side too so this is true they were
conducting a wellness they say uh quote
what's going on let me read they say
Paul Pelosi managed to call 9-1-1 and
alert this dispatcher to his dad
situation with without his eventual
attack or even knowing Pelosi the
husband blah blah blah the alleged
attacker David de Papi didn't realize
Pelosi had dialed his phone or
understood that Pelosi was speaking in
code what's going on why are you here
what are you going to do to me Pelosi
Pelosi Pelosi Pelosi allegedly said in
order to alert 9-1-1 to the emergency
situation see so this wellness check
wasn't random that's what I thought
happened he didn't make a phone call and
say hello there's a man in my house I
don't know him but he's my friend he was
speaking in code the people don't
believe this there were tons of viral
stories that have been around for a long
time of women who order pizza and
they'll say something they'll call 9-1-1
and say I'd like to order a large
pepperoni pizza ma'am this is 9-1-1 yes
I understand ma'am you're calling 9-1-1
it's not a pizza place yes I do
understand I would like to order a large
pizza and the dispatcher says are you in
danger ma'am yes and is this someone
threatening him yes and they're like
okay can you tell us what's going on are
you in danger I'm sorry I don't know and
they'll go okay and then the police show
up you like if you've got some crazy
person in front of you and you download
9-1-1 you can't go help police Quickie's
here because then you die
or you know I don't know I don't know it
could be anything but I'll tell you this
at the very least
going for the most like circuitous story
Paul Pelosi was having a secret gay
Rendezvous it got out of hand the police
showed up it's like yeah I don't believe
that I also don't believe the political
propaganda you can believe it if you
want I'm just saying tell that to one of
your Normie friends and see how quickly
they dismiss you and think you're insane
yeah stay away from from non-factual
proved proven things right now you got
it you gotta yeah that's why I'm always
like look sometimes the conspiracies are
true like the DHS store we have right
here we've long had this evidence but if
before these documents were released you
even now it's probably hard you go to
someone and say the government is
colluding with big Tech we've got these
this from this lawsuit people are going
to be like yeah you're crazy now we have
the intercept reporting a leftist
publication it's still going to be hard
because the story sounds so nuts I'm
just saying it may be true you just got
to be careful how you're presenting it
because it sounds ridiculous and it may
be and I recall the Andrew Gillum story
you know that was uh Ron desantis's uh
gubernatorial opponent in 2018 in
Florida and you know there was the story
there where you know he was he was found
you know in a drug-induced coma naked he
had naked you know having done all kinds
of drugs you know with a gay escort and
you know if those if the photographic
evidence of that Rendezvous didn't exist
that would all be dismissed as a
right-wing conspiracy theory so I mean
that's why it's so important and then
the DHS and the FBI would go to big Tech
social media companies because you got
to send to this right now make sure no
one talks about this if they do they get
uh kicked off so it's plausible that
right now the media is just trying to
get their story straight that they're
just that's why Politico is like country
near and Reporting like they're just
trying to get the narrative right you
know they got they say they got body
camera footage near post we'll say it's
it's in kind of police body cam so
release it yeah so where is it but you
know they're gonna they're like well you
know Paul's in his underwear and
I want to hear it more than anything
right
uh okay it's starting to sound a little
less nefarious now that he called the
cops spoken code that's exactly what
happened see when I when I heard the
dispatch call and they said he says he
doesn't know him but he's a friend
you know and he's waiting for his wife
and I saw everybody being like why would
he says he was his friend and I'm like
it's like those pizza phone calls where
the woman calls and says like me and you
know where we want pizza and they're
calling 9-1-1 he called in code
it's believable I I still think there's
something really off about them not
having security it doesn't make sense
right and the initial report of a third
person they're saying was just was a
misunderstanding
another person was there come on dude
like we have security and we don't we're
like one million of the value of the
Pelosi's like seriously yeah for real
yeah yeah it likes no sense to me yeah
it was a conscious act by them to not
have security present that raises a lot
of red flags or they had it and they're
they're saying they didn't to facilitate
a story they they just had the people in
they're like don't worry about it I know
the guy and then the guy's in there
right we didn't even have security it's
their budget I I think you know if I was
going to believe in there there was a
conspiracy or anything it'd probably be
that it was a break-in like the where's
Nancy wears Nancy stuff sounds way too
much like the fake AOC story where is
she where is yeah shut up that never
happened
like I'm sure the cop watch and said
where is she
where is she she's in the bathroom uh
ma'am you need to be evacuated and she's
like they're coming to get me and then
she lied about when it happened to make
it seem like the January 6 writers were
coming for her when her story took place
a full hour before the capital was even
breached well not in the capital in the
building and then she was not even in
the same building I want to fire off
some healing love to Paul
recover from the uh the head trauma
brother yeah man I hope he's okay like
it's a crazy story regardless I hope
that'll make him run for political
office anytime soon he's had a rough
year I mean just like yeah Baseline is
that a rough year I mean it's you know
self uh self-inflicted rough year Nancy
too It's gotta be stressful like I would
encourage you Nancy like you don't need
to be there I think that a lot of people
that are in Congress they feel like if
they leave they failed but at some point
you got to take care of yourself and
your family and let us take care of the
rest because we're here for you I think
it's like the Bear Bryant situation I
mean he he resisted retiring in Alabama
because he figured if he retired he
would die which he did six months later
like six months after he retired from
coaching football he was dead I think a
lot of these members of Congress they're
so Old Nation they don't want to die and
they they figure that hey if I go retire
then that'll be it'll be in the grade
because purpose keeps you alive yeah
sure that's right and work too people
who retire I think retirement age is
like the highest most likely time of
death absolutely you should never they
could keep working if they retire from
Congress yeah we shouldn't put humans in
a position where they're 85 and feel
like they can't stop being a
representative and they're probably and
their entire self-esteem and self-worth
is wrapped up in that office thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there